anomalous creatures in the scp
foundation's universe are not a rarity
dealing with anomalous sapien life forms
is the foundation's bread and butter
whether it's talkative sea slugs or a
body stealing swarm of ants for those of
you who haven't read their ethics
committee guidebooks sapient anomalies
are defined as creatures who have a keen
sense of self-awareness and can
communicate from the zaniness of dr
bright and his amulet to the neck
cracking scp-173
these sapient anomalous entities come in
all shapes and sizes but when does a
creature become so sapient they can be
considered anomalous take the humble
octopus for example who also just so
happens to be the subject of today's
video the octopus is a boneless
eight-legged creature capable of
shifting the color and texture of its
skin and will blast predators with a
black substance to blind them if i read
that in an scp foundation file i might
think those researchers found an alien
creature but no octopi or octopodes are
as you know real living breathing
creatures you can see at any aquarium
another interesting quirk of octopods is
their intelligence these creatures are
smart extremely smart hell they'll even
use fallen coconuts as a sort of armor
against enemies if tool use isn't
intelligence i don't know what is you
may be wondering how can you make an
octopus more anomalous than what i've
already described well today on scp
explained we'll be taking a look at
scp-2967 the sapient cephalopods to
answer that exact question we've all
probably been to aquariums dark ambient
rooms where the only light comes from
behind the massive tanks filled to the
brim with colorful fish and crustaceans
they can be fun to explore but when
you've seen a bunch of exotic fish once
it's not like you're clamoring to get
back in soon this was the problem faced
by the galaxy aquarium in may of 2010
attendance was low and profit was lower
the owner of the aquarium was a man by
the name of mark hemphill he was young
and extremely ambitious mark had an
interest in marine life since he was a
child and dedicated his life to studying
the creatures of the sea when he opened
the aquarium he had just gotten out of
college he hoped his passion and his
aquarium would inspire even just one
child to pursue the study of marine life
as he did mark's ambitious personality
was not going to let him watch his
life's work go to waste at a nearby
auction house the anomalous group of
interest marshall carter and dark were
organizing a showing for their new batch
of anomalous creatures available for
bidding seasoned viewers of scp
explained have likely run into anomalies
that marshall carter and dark have had a
hand in for those not in the loop
marshall carter and dark are dealers of
anomalous goods and services selling
anomalies to the highest bidder no
matter who they are from the average joe
to a tyrannical dictator marshall carter
and dark only care about cold hard cash
and getting as much of it as they can
mark hearing whispers of a massive
auction coming up decided to attend he
entered the auction house an old
dilapidated warehouse on the sketchy
side of town not exactly inspiring
confidence but mark thought maybe just
maybe there would be something for him
to add to his aquarium to get more
attendees mark walked through the heavy
metal doors to an immaculate auction
space the building was loaded with
well-dressed individuals who gazed over
the items they had for sale wooden
tables lined the walls of the warehouse
and on top of each table were tanks and
cages of creatures mark never thought
could exist from dogs that smelled like
candles two purple frogs that
telepathically communicated with the
people around them mark was convinced
that there was something here he could
use a staff member approached mark
almost immediately it was as if the
staff could smell the willingness to
spend money on him she was an older
woman dressed in a fine purple hued suit
she spoke with a comforting candor to
mark asking him about his day and what
brought him to the auction house she
introduced herself as jay and said that
the auction house had just the thing for
mark before he could even get the words
out they walked to the opposite side of
the building where a purple curtain was
erected walking through it was as if
mark had returned back to his aquarium
what were the odds that this place would
have a marine life section oddly for
such a well-designed room there was only
one small tank placed in it within it
was six octopodes a pale yellow in color
mark immediately recognized the species
as the common octopus the galaxy
aquarium already had a cephalopod
section with much more rare species than
the common octopus dejected mark almost
gave up hope before jay approached the
tank and kneeled jay seemed concerned
and called out the name levi from under
the table on which the tank stood a
massive octopus slithered into sight
startling mark it was at least five feet
in height and length that's impossible
mark thought there's no way that an
octopus of this species could get to be
this large the octopus's size was not
the only oddity it held though jay began
to scold levi for leaving its tank and
asked what it had to say for itself she
threw a sharpie marker to the ground for
levi who uncapped it and began to write
out the word sorry on the concrete floor
this couldn't be
mark thought there was absolutely no way
that an octopus can learn to understand
english let alone write it jay turned to
mark encouraging him to talk to levi uh
what's your name marc sheepishly he
couldn't believe he was trying to talk
to an octopus as soon as the words left
his mouth the octopus spelled out
l-e-v-i
with its marker mark couldn't believe it
this had to be some trick right some
sort of marketing gimmick to get him to
buy an overgrown piece of calamari there
is no way that an octopus could have
self-awareness mark knew they were smart
of course he had studied these things
for years but knowing its name that's
not possible what are you mark
questioned hoping to figure out if it
was an animatronic instead of a living
breathing animal levi began to write on
the floor again not a word this time but
a symbol the octopus first drew a large
oval then eight lines coming from the
bottom a crude drawing of an octopus
behind levi the other six octopodes were
watching him as spectators seeming to
clap when levi finished the drawing j
with a smug grin on her face asked mark
if he was impressed the look on mark's
face already told this story so jay
began to go over the pricing of the
creatures levi and the other six
octopodes were a packaged steel with a
starting bid for all seven placed at
three thousand dollars mark without a
second thought asked if he could
outright purchase levi and his
compatriots for ten thousand dollars
jay's smile grew wider and she shook
mark's hand without another word said
levi and the six other octopodes were
delivered to the galaxy aquarium the
next day within that time mark had
already prepared an unused section for
the arrival of his new attraction the
cephalopods were placed in their tanks
without much difficulty and settled into
their new home advertising began for the
galaxy aquarium's newest attraction the
talking octopus mark even splurged on a
billboard on the nearby highway this
investment was meant to save the
aquarium and for the next few months
attendance skyrocketed now we know why
the scp foundation keeps a heavy watch
over anomalous entities in the public
because all it takes is one ambitious
person before the entire world knows
that anomalies exist with the popularity
of levi it was a matter of time before
the scp foundation heard of it it was
time for an investigation site 12 was a
site dedicated to marine life and as
such many of the personnel stationed
there had the appropriate expertise to
deal with the anomaly agent hooper
volunteered for the investigation he was
ordered to pose as an animal behavior
specialist from the sea coral pacific
federation real creative their scp
foundation it just so happened that at
the same time agent hooper was getting
involved levi was beginning to give mark
a hard time at his aquarium it was a
late night in january 2011. the aquarium
had since closed after another day of
almost full attendance levi was not
sleeping however he was hungry and by
coincidence the section of the galaxy
aquarium next to levi's tank was a
potential all-you-can-eat buffet should
his plan come to fruition the next day
aquarium staff awoke to the filtration
system of the crab enclosure being
blocked by one of levi's friends it was
quickly removed and placed back into its
proper tank it wasn't out of the
ordinary for octopodes to escape their
tanks as i explained they are smart
creatures aquarium staff began the
process of moving the crabs to a
temporary tank while repairs and
cleaning on the original tank were
taking place as their attention was
drawn to the damaged filter and
contaminated crab tank levi managed to
escape and enter the unguarded temporary
tank of crabs broken shells and water
splattered the floor of the temporary
tank room as the feast began it was a
massacre levi ate 20 of the 40 crabs and
another 10 were dropped off into the
octopus's tank for levi's comrades
satisfied with its meal levi returned to
his tank as if nothing had happened an
hour passed before the leftovers of
levi's dinner were discovered and it
didn't take much guessing on the part of
aquarium staff to deduce who was behind
this agent hooper arrived the next day
and asked to meet with mark hooper
explained that he was from the sea coral
pacific federation and his place of
employment had heard of levi and wanted
to study him mark like a moth to a flame
eagerly took the opportunity to describe
the remarkable events of the previous
day hooper nodded along with the story
and promised to figure out why levi was
acting this way agent hooper was
escorted to the talking octopus section
of the aquarium and asked for some
privacy which he was granted levi was
sitting on a large mound of sand while
the smaller octopods sat in front of it
as if they were intently listening levi
was apparently lecturing the group using
a sharp rock to carve words and pictures
on the plexiglas walls of the tank agent
hooper knocked on the glass startling
the group in anger levi swam to the
front of the tank and stared at agent
hooper with a tentacle it knocked hard
on the glass and then endeavoured to
return to its lecture agent hooper
didn't catch the hint that he was
unwelcome and stayed uncomfortably close
to the glass until levi couldn't ignore
the agent any longer the octopus held up
five tentacles and made a shoeing motion
towards hooper who was incredibly
surprised hooper recognized the motion
as the phrase go away in sign language
hooper responded asking levi sign
language in sign language in response
levi once again held up five tentacles
and created what appeared to be a fist
then bobbed it back and forth like a
head nodding an octopus that knows sign
language not the most dangerous or
extraordinary anomaly that the
foundation has ever discovered but still
this anomaly could not remain out of
containment hooper quickly contacted the
research head at site 12 and explained
the situation he needed a containment
van for an aquatic anomaly a containment
force and class a amnestics immediately
this request was granted foundation
mobile task force lambda 12 pest control
stormed the building and wrangled the
aquarium staff into a closet so they
couldn't interfere the agents were
dressed in their tactical armor and held
large rifles but this was only to show
that they were meant to be taken
seriously and not to be used for force a
white unmarked containment van arrived
soon after foundation researchers ran
into the building and transported levi
and his students into the temporary
tanks of the containment van and made
sure they were securely closed and
locked multiple times when each octopus
was secured an airborne version of
a-class amnestics was distributed
throughout the aquarium by the mobile
task force agents leading to all
knowledge of levi being forgotten by the
aquarium's staff and mark for further
containment the scp foundation
distributed liquid amnestics into the
city's water supply so that anyone who
saw one of levi's performances would
forget that it ever happened the scp
foundation classified levi as scp-2967
and discovered the full extent of its
anomalous attributes
scp-2967 of course has the ability to
communicate through written language is
able to recognize and identify colors
symbols and individual figures of other
species and holds an abnormally high
intellect almost comparable to an
average human's intelligence the six
comrades of
scp-2967 were designated as
scp-2967-1 as they do not seem to be at
the same level of intellect as
scp-2967 through behavioral analysis and
research who has found that
scp-2967 will refer to
scp-2967-1 as its students friends or
army dr raynard the head researcher on
the
scp-2967 anomaly began hosting
intelligence checkups on scp-2967
every two weeks these consisted of levi
talking to dr raynard through the use of
a waterproof magnetic slate while the
doctor asked levi questions on one such
occasion the foundation discovered that
there may be more creatures similar to
scp-2967
and its students dr renard began by
drawing a crab an octopus and
scp-2967's toy he labeled them crab
friend and toy on its slate
scp-2967 wrote like and then a sketch of
a heart dr raynard drew a check mark on
his clipboard before rewarding
scp-2967 with a prawn following up dr
reynard asked if there was anything levi
didn't like to display this concept dr
raynard drew an x over a heart symbol
levi pause for a moment seeming to think
then drew what appeared to be a bird
with outstretched wings and an angular
beak upon finishing the drawing the
octopus's skin changed to a deep red
color levi wrote don't know word on his
slate then returned to its normal
colorization renard displayed a photo of
a pigeon to levi who marked an x on his
slate signifying that there was
something wrong before shifting its skin
black in response dr raynard returned to
a picture of a crow to levi who
scrambled to write on its slate that
word it wrote hastily renard responded
crow with his newfound knowledge levi
drew a heart with an x through it on its
slate then spelled out don't like crow
dr renard was confused how do two
species of creatures who live in
completely different habitats have a
disdain for each other
scp-2967 began to explain levi sketched
an octopus a crow in what appeared to be
a human over the head of the human levi
drew an arrow pointing at the human
before drawing a check mark over the
sketch of the octopus and the crow levi
connected the check marks to the arrow
above the human with two lines it seemed
that the crows and the octopods disdain
come from their common ability to
connect and grow fond of humans the
intelligence check concluded after levi
explained this to dr renard as the
octopus claimed it was tired and wanted
to return to its containment chamber the
next day however it seemed that
scp-2967 had correctly predicted what
would happen at site-12. on april 3 2011
research staff at site-12 reported a
high concentration of american crows
surrounding the building many were
perched in trees or on the roof of the
site but some were simply hovering near
the entrances seeming to hope that the
door would open while the crows weren't
aggressive to humans who would fly to a
window connected to the containment
chamber of scp-2967
and peck on it this continued for hours
and it seems that the crows were
threatening levi and his friends the
foundation deployed mobile task force
lambda 4 bird watchers to site 12. this
team was not armed in your standard
tactical gear and heavy weaponry they
were camouflaged clothing with shoes
that muffled their footsteps in grassy
environments they had jackets of thick
leather to prevent injuries from talons
or beaks and they had specialized pellet
guns they used to incapacitate anomalous
birds they began by shooting the birds
away and capturing a few using nets for
further study as they concluded all but
one of the crows dispersed this crow was
similar to levi much larger compared to
non-anomalous members of its species the
large crow flew 10 feet from the
entrance of the site and spat the
decaying remains of one common octopus
out onto the asphalt parking lot before
retreating the bird watchers attempted
to follow the group of crows but the
flock was impossible to track what was
found however was an area in a nearby
forest that contained an abnormally
large number of feathers belonging to
the american crow species as well as
numerous small makeshift huts made of
sticks and dying leaves and a collection
of various litter fashioned into basic
tools such as hammers made of bolts and
toothbrushes the most surprising item
retrieved during this exploration was
the torn remnants of a copy of the
documentation for scp-2967
kept in the largest hut as is standard
the scp foundation enacted surveillance
procedures on this location placing
hidden cameras and microphones as well
as traps the large crow has been
classified as scp-2967-b
so it seems that the animal kingdom is
at war for the favor of the human race
while the foundation only knows for sure
that octopods and crows are at battle
there may be many more species out there
who look to curry our favor who do you
think will be the victor should battle
commence now go check out
scp-247 a harmless kitten and
scp-1111 the white dog for more
anomalous animals that defy expectations